what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and today sony and
marvel studios have begun to release
bonus content and teasing more bonus
content for spider-man no way home and
in this little teaser promo that we got
today we actually see toby mcguire
talking about how he is down for
anything now this could possibly be a
hint at the future we know toby maguire
has been rumored to be appearing in
other marvel projects such as another
spider-man film or perhaps doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness so
are they teasing that we're gonna watch
this clip together plus we have another
clip as well but we're gonna break down
what is said and what is happening so
let's dive into it and if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest marvel news okay so
sony released this just this morning a
little preview of some bonus content
that is coming from a choreography
standpoint it's interesting because
spider-man's never fought with
spider-man before and i think what we
want to try and explore is an element of
trying to figure each other out and
figure out our each individual unique
styles of how to be spider-man
[Music]
he is chomping at the [ __ ] oh my god i
just can't and it's been killing me
because of the whole secrecy thing
because i want to go around and go hey
wait on wires
i'm open for anything i'm ready to go
and that's about it to be honest with
you
oh
i'm open for anything
oh to me that's just like
what do you mean by that now
again the rumors are flying pretty heavy
right now that he's gonna appear in
another spider-man film and fingers are
crossed about this now we're gonna find
out more when this actually releases and
we get all of this content we can
actually watch it and break it down
but i'm pretty sure toby would be up to
come back as spider-man again it sounded
like he had the time of his life it
sounded like it was just nothing but fun
and nothing but nostalgia and a great
time for him i mean he even says that
when he was hanging from the wires when
he was doing these stunts for spider-man
knowing home he wanted to tell everybody
but of course he was sworn to secrecy
about everything but that's good news
because he wanted to tell the world i'm
back as spider-man look i'm back in
these bungee rubs i'm doing stunts look
i'm all suited up i'm back i'm back a
spider-man and that excitement probably
doesn't end with spider-man no way home
especially since the rumors say that
they're going to do another team-up
movie with the three spider-man again
whether that's spider-man 4 whether
that's spider-man 5 spider-man 6 at some
point in time it would make sense that
the spider-man would meet up again even
though in the ending of spider-man no
way home they kind of all went their
separate ways and went back to their own
universes it doesn't mean that they
can't meet up again now one point that i
would like to mention is that pretty
much for the most part all of the leaks
about spider-man knowing home kind of
ended up becoming true a lot of the
movie was actually kind of out there
before spider-man no way home went into
theaters but fortunately for us the
scenes were so amazing that the leaks
didn't even matter watching it on screen
was just a fantastic historic moment but
now some of the same people who released
some of these leaks are saying that
andrew and toby are going to be
returning eventually and after seeing
the chemistry of these three off screen
which is something that i really wanted
to see because of course the chemistry
on scene was perfect but off screen
watching them just mess around and laugh
with each other that's amazing it's
great that they have good friendships
with each other because that's also
really good for us who want them all to
get together in a movie again now let's
talk about perhaps the most important
thing that has happened this happened
yesterday they finally did the pointing
meme if you haven't seen this clip don't
worry we'll watch it right now and if
you have seen it let's watch it again
we're going to lift you up on a cherry
picker and you're going to jump off
[Music]
80 minutes how they became super
villains it's just so fun
i fell into a super collider gotta be
careful where you fall
to work with them is honestly the
highlight of my career me and toby
arrived and all of their arms were just
open
they're pointing out the easter eggs for
us
i had butterflies with me and andrew
hoping they would sign up
why wouldn't they
april 12th so we have to wait till april
12th but in this we obviously saw really
quickly the clip of i think it was
andrea was pointing at the other two
spider-man and shortly after that tom
holland released on his instagram and
sony released it in marvel studios as
well they released the official meme
photo of the three spider-man pointing
at each other that's all i wanted that's
really all i wanted when i heard that
the three spider-man were going to be in
the film together i was like they have
to do the meme i wanted like a couple of
things i wanted them to do the meme
because it would be such a missed
opportunity if they didn't do that and
they did it in a really good way in the
movie they didn't just stand there and
do that because that wouldn't really
have made sense for the story but they
did it in a way that made sense but then
they released the actual photo of them
copying the meme that's what i wanted
and then i wanted them to talk about you
know the web blood organic web shooters
versus you know mechanized web shooters
and they did that and they made a joke
about it as well asking if it comes out
any other place and it was just perfect
and this is the kind of stuff that we're
going to see
in this behind the scenes footage 80
minutes of behind the scenes footage 20
minutes of extra footage with toby and
andrew interacting with tom holland's
peter parker i'm definitely here for
that i'll definitely of course be
breaking that down as soon as they
release that it also looks like they're
going to be pointing out easter eggs
themselves which
kind of makes my job easier but it looks
like they might be trying to put me out
of a job but we'll of course find more
easter eggs i'm sure but it'll be really
cool to go over that as well now as far
as spider-man 4 or the next spider-man
movies are concerned we have heard quite
a few rumors at this point and if you're
not aware of what they are here's what
people are saying could possibly happen
now of course this is not confirmed but
is a possibility one rumor of course is
that toby mcguire could actually get his
spider-man 4 movie if you're not aware
toby maguire was supposed to have four
spider-man films not three and they were
supposed to all be with sam raimi so
toby and sam raimi had a fourth movie
that actually ended up getting cancelled
from what we know it was actually going
to be pretty intense and the villain was
going to be vulture now sam raimi is
back directing multiverse of madness and
toby maguire has just returned as
spider-man so perhaps the two of them
will team up once again and give us a
spider-man 4. of course again this is
just rumor speculation right now this is
not confirmed but kind of the same thing
goes for andrew garfield rumors are
going around that he could finally get
his the amazing spider-man 3 movie he
was supposed to have a third movie that
got cancelled because marvel studios
stepped in with sony and told them that
they had to do a new spider-man and that
it had to be in the mcu and feige was
definitely right about that one but
andrew garfield has returned
triumphantly people loved his
performance in spider-man no way home
and people really want the amazing
spider-man 3 and they've even signed a
petition some insiders say that marvel
studios and sony are considering and
want to do an amazing spider-man 3 movie
or at least have andrew garfield show up
in a sony spider-man universe movie like
perhaps in venom 3 he could be the
spider-man that goes up against venom
and i really actually hope this happened
so fingers crossed on this one and of
course the biggest rumor is that the
three spider-men will unite again and do
another film together this time however
they will all be together from the start
it was fantastic to see the three
spiderman on film but they did come in
in pretty much the last act and one can
only imagine how awesome and epic a
movie would be if the three of them were
all in it from the very first act so
again fingers crossed that this happens
and considering the fact that spider-man
no way home was one of the biggest
movies of all time during a pandemic it
would make sense that marvel studios and
sony wants to capitalize on this again
and of course the fans want it so why
not give the fans what they want and
also make money yourselves but hopefully
we find out a little bit more ourselves
when all of this bonus content comes out
in a little under two months in the
meantime let me know what you think
about this in the comments down below
which movie would you like to see the
amazing spider-man 3 spider-man 4 with
tobey maguire or another spider-man
where the three of them team up let me
know don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest marvel news for live
updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof